las estrechas callejuelas del cementerio
de cap haitien no estaban vacías el
miércoles fue un día salpicado de
decenas de funerales
75 personas que han sido enterradas se
ha tenido que usar también otros
cementerios cruzados en el lugar de la
explosión la maquinaria entra en acción
para destruir los edificios en ruinas
que amenazaban con derrumbarse
el escenario de la tragedia comienza a
aclararse el lunes por la noche un
camión cisterna intentó esquivar un mono
taxi perdió el control el vehículo volcó
y derramó el combustible que algunos
transeúntes trataron de recoger a pesar
del peligro
cuando vi que la gasolina empezaba a
fluir pedía a los habitantes que
evacuaran la zona les advertí del
peligro de que podía explotar
esta mujer ha perdido a su hijo de 36
años este hombre a seis hijos ya su
yerno el primer ministro ha declarado
tres días de luto nacional hasta el
viernes incluido haití uno de los países
más pobres del mundo se enfrenta desde
hace meses a una escasez de gasolina
debido a que las bandas criminales se
apoderan de parte del suministro el país
ha vivido recientemente un periodo de
inestabilidad política tras el asesinato
de job en el móvil el pasado julio